- We used to be
a family of two.
- Now look at us.
- Here we are.
Yeah, it's pretty big out there.
And I'm sure your head must be
filled with questions.
Now then, let's see...
- Welcome to planet Earth.
There is much
to see and do here,
so let's get started
with a quick tour.
♪ When I head off ♪
- Come on!
♪ For new adventures ♪
- Life on Earth
is a wonderful thing.
- Wow!
- It looks big, but there are
lots of us on here.
We may all look different,
but don't be fooled.
We are all people.
- Hello!
- And we all share the Earth.
- The world is so huge that...
no matter how much I learn,
it'll never be enough!
- It sounds like you feel...
- Lost.
- If you're feeling lost,
just start with what you know.
- Hello, birds!
Look at that!
Wow!
- There is so much more for you
to learn about planet Earth.
Make sure you look after it,
as it's all we've got.
- For the first time in his life,
he's speechless.
♪ Remind myself
when I'm in the darkness ♪